this evening Jewish people all across
the country and around the world will
celebrate Passover it's a chance for
families to come together for a festive
meal and tell the story of Jews escape
from slavery thousands of years ago but
social distancing is forcing millions of
Americans to find new ways to connect
CBS this morning Saturday co-host Dana
Jacobson shows us Passover in the midst
of a pandemic this is your
great-grandmother's Erin bina is cooking
for Passover with her two-year-old son
Ethan by her side this is how the
holiday usually looks for Erin Edie and
their large family but now amid the
pandemic she's prepping alone for the
first time we cook together we sing
together we tell stories together this
year it's gonna be a little sadder their
celebration will now be a virtual one
breaking the tradition this year is
really hard especially with our son who
loves my grandparents so much you really
watch as my grandfather with great awe
when he sings the prayers social
distancing has created a new reality for
Passover Aileen Schick heads kitchen is
also usually bustling with activity as
she gets ready for the holiday it's a
big deal in our family the traditions
that we have the special songs that we
see a lot of people a lot of energy it's
a new time for all of us the coronavirus
has created chaos at markets shopping
for Passover necessities added an extra
layer of anxiety how frustrating was
shopping during a pandemic oh my
goodness it was terrible I'm making a
big pot of matzo ball soup and I have to
have it to make the matzo balls Aileen
and her daughter Sophie usually host a
raucous seder complete with puppets and
song we're finding a way to take our
Passover Seder to the next level but
like the preparations
this year's will be different they've
asked family and friends to join there's
a dur or zoom Seder we're going from the
Czech Republic to Seattle
we have Georgia and Virginia we're in
Florida the kids are used to having the
same traditions and we're showing them
we're not panicking we're not worried
we're making the very best of this
situation and it is going to be a
Passover that for sure we will never
forget never forgetting is at the heart
of this ancient tradition that has
celebrated freedom from oppression for
some 3,000 years we these bitter herbs
that make us cry a lot of people have
been crying every day recently just
trying to get through this do what you
can do Rabbi Ari ever back leads temple
that's time near Los Angeles what it
means to host a seder and will be
hosting virtual Saders I think people
need to share their stories Passover is
very symbolic we have all these symbols
on the Seder Plate in the middle of the
table and ask people if you could add
something to the Seder Plate this year
something symbolic of what we're going
through what would it be somebody in our
community said have analemma reminds us
you can make lemonade out of lemons
which is delicious and kosher for
Passover
not even a pandemic can stop the music
die a new is the traditional song of
thanks heard at satyrs worldwide the
acapella group the Maccabeats put a
modern spin on nicely most Jews have
always found a way to carry on the
tradition even during times of war and
conflict while the virus is shaking
things up especially for Orthodox Jews
forbidden from using any
videoconferencing during the holiday
this year's celebration of resilience
and renewal will go on this is another
way that we are overcoming what we have
gone through in order to be able to be
together and make it a joyful occasion
next year we'll all be together for CBS
this morning Dana Jacobson New York